ce char et russes avancent dans les rues
de marioupol la scène est filmée par un
groupe nationaliste ukrainien l'engin
est frappé quelques instants plus tard
ce soldat en bas de l'image se rend
courant puis s'enfuit à plat ventre
[Musique]
la résistance est à char n'est entré
samedi dans marioupol les russes peinent
à progresser dans cette cité portuaire
stratégique dans ce message diffusé par
le ministère de la défense il appelle
les soldats ukrainien à déposer les
armes
nous demandons aux autorités officielles
de kiev d'être raisonnable et d'annuler
les instructions données précédemment
qui obligeait les militants à se
sacrifier à devenir les martyrs de
marioupol
un ultimatum rejeté par l'ukraine qui
refuse de parler de reddition ou de
déposer les armes pilonnée sans relâche
depuis 19 jours marioupol a des allures
de ville fantôme
une école d'art où 400 personnes étaient
réfugiés a été bombardé on ignore pour
le moment le bilan de cette attaque
80% des infrastructures seraient
endommagées ou détruites
les rues sont jonchées de cadavres et la
plupart des 400 mille habitants sont
piégés sur place dans le froid sans
accès à l'électricité
cette femme s'est réfugiée dans une cave
depuis 11 jours
qu'on cuisine à l'aide d'un feu pour
l'instant nous avons de la nourriture et
du bois mais dans une semaine nous
n'aurons plus rien qu'allons nous faire
les nations unies dénoncent une
situation humanitaire extrêmement grave
les habitants sont confrontés à une
pénurie potentiellement mortelle d'eau
et de nourriture